this is the king cobra the longest
venomous snake in the world this is a
dangerous dangerous dangerous snake and
the venom from one bite is enough to
kill 20 people so the last thing Bally's
Pooh - Eddie should do is this
amazing it must be love Eddy rescues
nuisance snakes from local villages then
releases them back into the wild either
this guy is really stupid or really
brainy how is Eddie charming this snake
into a long kiss goodbye Eddie knows
that the key to capturing or kissing a
Cobra lies with distraction you can see
him wiggling his head and moving that
stick around to kind of transfixed the
Cobra once the king cobra is transfixed
Eddie moves down very very slowly in
order to plant the kiss on its head
snakes don't tend to perceive
slow-moving objects as much of a threat
this tank is essentially a backbone
surrounded by 10,000 muscles it's very
strong and very agile if we wanted to
get away it could if it wanted to strike
it Eddie you could do that too so really
the snake is probably just confused
about why Eddie would want to kiss it
and honestly so am i the snake gets a
nice new home and maybe Eddie gets a
second date